I'm nine chanda editor of Elle global
online and we are delighted to have with
us in our studio mat chronic he is
assistant professor of political science
at Georgetown University and an expert
on non-proliferation issues steptronic
has written several books the most
recent one is exporting the bomb
technology transfer and spirit of
nuclear weapons so welcome to El thank
you it's a pleasure to be here so you
have Britain a very very thought
provoking and even controversial essay
in foreign affairs basically calling for
action to stop Iran from producing the
bomb now some people have said that the
Cure may be worse than the disease the
consequences of a strike on iran to stop
them from producing the bomb my tab
consequences which could be far worse
than the onions holding on to a couple
of bombs so what's your answer to that
yeah well I'm afraid Munna comes to
Iran's nuclear program we really have no
good options I mean if we could solve
this diplomatically I think that would
clearly be be preferable but I think
there's good reason to think that we can
the two sides just seems so far apart
and Iran's nuclear program continues to
progress so if that's the case then
we're left with this set of bad options
that you point out simply acquiescing to
a nuclear-armed Iran or taking military
action designed to stop Iran from
acquiring nuclear weapons and so they're
serious downside consequences to both
it's of course impossible to know how
these two scenarios would play out but
it's an issue I've given a lot of
thoughts who I worked as an advisor on
Iran policy for a year at the Department
of Defense and it's my judgment that
they're bad options but that the
military strike is the least bad option
that if you think about the consequences
of a nuclear-armed Iran for four decades
to come that the cost there would be I
think much more significant than the
costs of the limited strike on iran's
key nuclear facilities
okay let's look at it from first of all
from the point of view of feasibility of
an air strike or missile strike on
nuclear Natanz or other installations
how certain can one be that it would
actually end the program or simply
delayed yeah so first I think it's
important to distinguish between
Israel's military option and the United
States military option so I think those
things are often conflated in the public
debate but it's a mistake to do so
because the United States simply put has
much greater capabilities to inflict
lasting damage on Iran's nuclear
facilities and so I don't think that the
Israeli military option is a good one
because simply i don't think they have
enough capability to really set back the
program the United States on the other
hand does and so when you're looking at
the key facilities that you would want
to destroy in Iran's nuclear program
their thumbs is the one or so I think
there are four and possibly five that
you would want to get so there's the
uranium enrichment facility at Natanz
that you point out that's underground
there's the uranium enrichment facility
at comm which is buried in the side of a
mountain there's the anakim is the holy
site in its near it's near a holy city
that's correct and then there's the
uranium conversion facility at s bahan
and then let's see Natanz calm isfahan
the other key facilities at escaping me
at the moment but but it's also
underground so both the United States
and Israel could destroy the above
ground facilities the two above ground
facilities Natanz and comb are more
difficult but the United States has
developed a new bunker-busting bomb the
massive ordnance penetrator sometimes
abbreviated as the mall that according
to open source information can penetrate
200 feet of reinforced concrete so that
would be enough to destroy Natanz and
calm so so in other words if israel
initiates the action unless us joins in
this would only provoke Iran in
degeneration but not really do the job
that is that is intended to do right
yeah so with either a us or Israeli
strike there would be significant
consequences including Iranian military
retaliation so if you're going to take
military action and incur those costs I
think you want to be able to inflict as
much damage on the program as you can
impose as much a delay on the progress
as you can and so as I said Israel could
destroy the above ground facilities but
probably not the underground facilities
and so the estimates there that Israel
could set an Israeli strike could set
the program back somewhere between one
and three years whereas a US strike
which would do much more damage it's
estimated would set the program back
somewhere five to seven years so again I
think weighing those two options that
the US option is clearly superior you
buy much more time and and I think the
United States could also deal better
with a lot of the negative consequences
including Iranian military retaliation
including some of the diplomatic fallout
like liver let's see so if the US
doesn't get involved then Israeli strike
would be more provocative but less
effective in terms of achieving subject
and Iranian reaction what what is are
your expectations what the onions could
do in case of an Israeli strike yeah so
many people argue that a us or Israeli
strike on iran's nuclear facilities
would somehow lead to a broad regional
war and I just don't think that's likely
i think the consequences are serious but
it's it's hard for me to imagine it
becoming a region-wide war and so first
i think it's important to concentrate on
iran's capabilities and what could I Ron
do in the event of an attack and then to
look at their kind of intentions what
would their likely response V so in
terms of capabilities Ron doesn't have a
strong conventional military rather
they've been developing these asymmetric
military options so they have a
stockpile of ballistic missiles that
they could use to shoot at population
centers or US forces and bases that
simply explosive simple explosive not
not chemical or
but biological yeah well we do think
that they have chemical and biological
weapons but they're they're larger
stockpiles are of basic conventional
weapons which which we think they would
be most likely to be damaging buildings
and killing people but in a radius not
very big I suppose that's right and
they're also not very accurate so if
they aim them at cities say Tel Aviv
they would certainly do some damage but
if they tried to aim them at US bases or
ships or at the Israeli nuclear reactor
at dimona which some people think might
be a likely target and kind of a
tit-for-tat strike then it's likely that
a lot of these missiles would miss their
target and land somewhere in the desert
so you know it's serious consequence but
you know not not a region-wide war you
know Iran has about 300 of these
shahab-3 ballistic missiles but they
only have 10 launchers so they can only
shoot 10 at a time so my best estimate
is that they would maybe shoot four or
five salvos so 40 or 50 ballistic
missiles would be their first
retaliatory option second they have ties
to terrorists and proxy groups so they
would likely encourage Hamas encouraged
Hezbollah to conduct rocket attacks into
Israel but it's important to recognize
that Hamas and Hezbollah have their own
strategic calculations they're not
simply going to salute and do whatever
iran says and I think that there's
really good reason to believe that
Hezbollah in particular is worried about
another israeli invasion into southern
lebanon so i think they would have this
kind of strategic dilemma of wanting to
strike back but not too hard so I think
that we'd likely see kind of token
rocket fire from Hamas and Hezbollah so
that's the second major retaliatory
response I think we'd see and then third
Iran has the ability to cause havoc in
the Persian Gulf with this IRGC Navy so
they could attack and harass ships in
the Persian Gulf and the worst are there
kind of most damaging retaliatory option
and the Persian Gulf would be to try to
close this Strait of Hormuz this narrow
passageway through which most of the
world's large portion of the world's oil
passes but so that's that's what I Ron
could do so so that would be an action
against the war not in sterling it's
Israel at closing the state
formals and so so the despite the
limited ability that you mentioned about
the Iranian military the devastation
still would be pretty significant in
terms of loss of life and property and
and particularly on the walls energy
supply so that's the one side of the
ledger the other side of the ledger is
letting Iran develop enough enriched
uranium to make a couple of bombs or
more what is the downside to letting
Iran have those bombs yeah well I think
a nuclear-armed Iran would have grave
consequences for international peace and
security so first I think it would
likely lead to further proliferation in
the region so if Iran acquired nuclear
weapons I think it's very likely the
turkey egypt saudi arabia perhaps other
countries would seek to acquire nuclear
weapons in response iran i think would
likely become a nuclear supplier it
would likely transfer uranium enrichment
technology to other countries probably
outside the Middle East maybe Latin
America Asia other places so I think the
first negative consequences you would
see is kind of a weakening of the global
non-proliferation regime and the spread
of nuclear weapons to too many other
countries so it's not just a problem of
Iran it's a problem of proliferation
more broadly second I think a
nuclear-armed Iran would be more
aggressive in terms of its foreign
policy right now we know that Iran
limits its foreign policy because it
fears major us an example what what
would you see as a possibility of union
being more aggressive and one nay one
idea yeah well so for example when it
comes to support for terrorists and
proxy groups which is something that
Iran does now we know that they limit
what they do because they fear that if
they push too hard they provide some of
their most advanced military technology
to terrorist groups that are then used
against the United States or Israel or
other countries that that might invite a
devastating military response from the
United States so Iran is self deterred
from going too far on that front if they
had nuclear weapons on the other hand if
I felt like they could deter a major us
or Israeli military response then there
would be no reason for them to hold back
so I think they would likely step up
their support to terrorists and proxy
groups and would probably be more
aggressive in terms of their just goals
in the region and coercive diplomacy in
the region so if Iran is is becoming
more aggressive in a region with
multiple nuclear-armed states it could
become an even more crisis prone region
and so when you have crises involving
nuclear-armed states there's always a
risk that things could spin out of
control and result in nuclear exchange
so you know meaningful so so the way you
are describing it to the Iran is kind of
launched on a path to dominate the
region by developing nuclear weapon to
call other peoples to submission or but
is what is their objective is it is it
an imperial ambition or is it what what
do you think is driving them what is it
as some people say simply purely
defensive because Iran in Israel has
nuclear weapons and Israel is a sewn
enemy of Iran so Iran has to have them
so what do you think is the jail Iranian
motive you know obtaining the nuclear
weapon on this question we can
essentially ask the Iranians themselves
because Iran just like the United States
publishes its own national security
strategy and this has been the US
Department of Defense every year
provides a report on Iranian military
power where they talk about Iran's
strategic goals and so the Iranians say
very clearly that their two most
important strategic goals are first to
be able to deter us or Israeli attack
and second to become the most dominant
state in the Middle East and so they're
very clear about this desire to be a
regional hegemon and I think acquiring
nuclear weapons themselves helps them to
achieve both of these goals it helps
them to deter us or Israeli attack and
it provides this cover under which they
can be more aggressive and more
expansionist and their goals in the
region and
this domination is it is it the passion
domination or is it a sheer domination
what what is the what is the driving
force behind this desire to dominate is
it created she I Empire mmm what's a
good question i mean you know many
international relations theorists john
mearsheimer at the university of chicago
maybe the most well-known argue that all
states at the end of the day want
security but the best way to be secure
is to be powerful and to be more
powerful than your neighbors so I think
this desire on Iran's part two to be one
of the most dominant states in the
Middle East makes sense kind of from a
rational point of view I think many
states would like to be in that position
if they could the flip side of that of
course though is that as Iran becomes
more powerful it threatens its neighbors
threatens the United States and US
interest in the region so while it might
make sense for a run to have nuclear
weapons from from their point of view I
think there's also very good reason for
the United States and the West to be
very concerned and fearful of that
capability mm-hmm and in this equation
where does Saudi Arabia and other an
Egypt fitting are the supportive of the
us or Israeli position then Iran should
not have this nuclear weapons well the
Arab states are in a difficult spot on
one hand from a strategic point of view
they're very threatened by Iran's
capabilities and you know there have
been many reports of leaders Saudi
leaders coming to the United States and
asking the United States to take action
probably the best known example is a
Saudi one of the Saudi princes that's
the United States to quote cut the head
off the snake referring to Iran's
nuclear capability on the other hand a
US and especially in Israeli military
strike on Iran would be unpopular I
think among populations in the Arab
world as so these Arab leaders are in a
difficult spot of strategically wanting
to stop Iran but in order to maintain
legitimacy domestically not being able
to go too far so I think what would
likely happen is that if a strike were
to take place they might condemn the
United States or Israel and public
but congratulate us behind closed doors
that competition is fine but if the
people in the street they're outraged by
attack on a fellow Islamic country how'd
that ensure stability and security of
this country's yeah so I think one thing
that's always important to keep in mind
is when considering the negative
consequences of a strike and there are
many is to also compare those to the
negative consequences of the alternative
simply doing nothing and allowing Iran
to acquire nuclear weapons so I think
your question is absolutely right that a
strike would likely lead to
anti-american sentiment in the Middle
East on the other hand if we allow Iran
to acquire nuclear weapons the United
States would have to put in a deterrence
and containment regime to deal with that
so that would actually mean a major
increase of us political and military
commitments in the region I think it
would mean probably signing formal
defense pacts with Saudi Arabia perhaps
with Israel maybe other Gulf states so
essentially we'd be promising to fight a
nuclear war on their behalf that's kind
of an inherently incredible threat so we
would want to do things to make that
threat more credible so what we did
during the Cold War to make those
threats to defend Europe and defend East
Asia credible where to forward deploy US
troops for deploy US nuclear weapons on
the territory of our allies to ensure
that we'd get dragged into any conflict
so I think if you think about it
deterrence and containment regime in the
Middle East we'd likely do something
similar I think it could mean deploying
US troops deploying us nuclear weapons
on on Saudi territory on in the
territory of other Gulf states perhaps
of Israel so I think those are the kinds
of things that would also lead to
anti-american sentiment in the region so
I think either way we're in bad shape
when we think it so and anti-americanism
in Middle East we have to live with that
is that ultimately you're saying I think
so I think either way we go we're going
to have some anti-american sentiment
there will just be different flavors is
it because of our increased military in
political commitments to the region to
determine contain a nuclear-armed Iran
which could likely last for
decades as long as Iran has nuclear
weapons or would it be the perhaps more
intense but short-term reaction from
kinetic action against Iran's nuclear
facilities so we have looked at two
options letting Iran develop its nukes
and stopping it right now how would the
the course that the administration of
ominous train is pursuing is putting a
tremendous amount of pressure and hoping
that Iran would not proceed further to
develop the nuclear weapon they have in
this material and maybe they could be
stopped at a point when they cannot
produce the material and even surely
perhaps could be persuaded to go the
route of South Africa or Libya in
actually not in destroying what have
they done now is that is that something
that you think is impossible what is
your reading of the current situation
yeah well as I said at the beginning of
the interview if we can solve this
diplomatically and avoid this really
gut-wrenching choice between military
action in nuclear-armed Iran that would
be ideal and so I think the
administration is right to pursue this
sanctions and diplomacy route as long as
they can I'm just very skeptical that
we're going to get a deal for a number
of reasons first the diplomatic track
has essentially stalled out we had a
number of meetings this summer but all
we could agree to in those meetings were
to have further media meeting between
the European countries on Iran right and
well in the United States had
representatives there as well as the
United States the European countries and
Iran and we couldn't get to deal and all
we could agree to was additional
meetings and then at this point we
haven't even been able to agree to two
additional meetings and I think that the
two sides are just so far apart at this
point I mean it's very hard for me to
imagine what the deal would even look
like that would that Iran's supreme
leader would be willing to agree to in
terms of curbs on his program
that would simultaneously reassure the
United States and reassure the West that
Iran's nuclear program is no longer a
problem and so the tool the
administration the primary tool the
administration has been using to try to
pull Iran closer to a deal that we could
agree to is by putting on these
difficult of sanctions which are having
saw impact right now the economy's
healing so as i like to say the
sanctions are having an effect just not
the effect that we want so they are
clearly hurting the Iranian economy but
the point of course isn't just to punish
Iranians it's to convince Ron's
government that in order to come out
from under the sanctions that they need
to make put serious curbs on their
nuclear program and so far we've seen no
evidence that this is leading Iran's
supreme leader or the Iranian government
to reconsider the nuclear program so
they're clearly concerned that the
sanctions are hurting the economy yet
the nuclear program continues to move
full steam ahead mm-hmm the Ayatollah
Khomeini has said that nuclear weapon is
haram having said that it doesn't that
give the west and the unis tears in
opening to say yes we also believe it is
haram for Islam and we should help you
to not do this so what you think you
just apply its they don't they don't
believe in what they're saying well I'm
an expert on nuclear weapons
proliferation and I've studied the
military component of our strategy to
Iran both in terms of a strike and it
turns in containment I'm not an expert
on on Muslim theology so I won't pretend
to be but but I have talked to many and
one thing that I hear is that the
supreme leader can make these statements
but can also retract them or change them
in the future depending on circumstances
and so one example they give is during
the Gulf War or the the first iran-iraq
war excuse me during the 1980s that
Iran's supreme leader at the time had
said that developing weapons of mass
destruction was haraam but then once
Saddam Hussein started using
weapons of mass destruction against Iran
then they changed their mind and said
it's necessary to protect the
Revolutionary Government in Iran and
that that was a religious objective in
and of itself that was important enough
to override the previous statements
against developing weapons of mass
destruction so it seems to me like he
could do something similar here to say
well I had said that nuclear weapons are
haram previously but in order to save
the Revolutionary Government which is an
important religious goal in and of
itself then I retract my previous
statement and we need to develop nuclear
weapons so what what is your estimate of
the status of Iran's nuclear weapons
program are the five percent away from
from producing it or is what what is
what is your reading yeah one order to
develop nuclear weapons around needs to
do two things first they need to develop
enough highly enriched uranium and
second they need to take that uranium
and fashioned it into a nuclear weapon
so actually constructing a simple gun
type nuclear weapon once you have the
enriched uranium it is fairly simple the
long pole in the tent as they say is is
getting enough of the highly enriched
uranium so right now Iran is enriching
to twenty percent in order to build
nuclear weapons they would have to
enrich to ninety percent so the question
really is how long if the Supreme Leader
made the decision today would it take a
run to develop to enrich from twenty
percent to ninety percent to have enough
for one nuclear weapon I think that's
really the key threshold point and so
downside experts who have looked at this
David Albright in Washington is one
estimate that if they made that decision
today it would take somewhere between
two and four months to get enough
material so I think two months is kind
of the minimum time that we would have
but as long as the supreme leader
doesn't make that decision to enrich
above twenty percent that timeline will
continue to be pushed out but how about
designing a bomb because they so far
there is no evidence that they have
actually tested any explosive device or
trigger mechanism
and once they have done that then they
have to also miniaturize it to make it
the payload of a rocket which is again a
very very complex task so what is your
estimator how long even if they in four
months time they have enough enriched
uranium to make a bomb how long will it
take for them to actually turn that into
a usable payload on a rocket yeah well
this is a great question because I think
the administration often points out
these longer time lines of well first
they would have to have material then
they would have to weaponize it then
they would have to get it small enough
to fit on the nose kind of ballistic
missiles so we're looking at years and
that's true but I think it's actually
irrelevant because when it comes to our
options the military option is really
only good until they have the material
because right now we can strike these
facilities to prevent them from
producing the material once they produce
the material the game's over because
they could take that and move it
anywhere put it in underground
facilities we probably wouldn't even
know where it is so at that point our
military option our only military option
would be a full-scale invasion to search
the country for this in rich geranium
and that's I think not an option that
would be seriously considered anytime
soon given the just what happened in
Iraq and Afghanistan so if we want to
preserve this military option then it
has to be before they develop enough
enriched uranium and so that's why
there's been something of a debate about
red lines I'm actually in favor of
setting red lines to make it very clear
that if they were to enrich to ninety
percent that's kind of the point of no
return for us we'd either have to use
force then or or not at all and so on
how sure can you be about the extent of
enrichment that they have done so that
that red line actually is operational
yeah how do you know that so it's a good
question so we we have a pretty good
window into Iran's nuclear program
because the International Atomic Energy
Agency inspectors are there so there I
inspectors are permanently
they visit the key declared nuclear
facilities about every two weeks and
they write detailed reports every three
months or so so we have a very good
sense of what's there so if we're on
were to enrich above twenty percent at
Natanz or comb then the IAEA inspectors
are there taking samples they would
detect it within about two weeks which
is how often they're visiting the
facilities now there is the question of
possible unknown facilities what if they
have facilities we don't know about
where they're enriching and that would
be a problem I think it's unlikely for a
number of reasons that they have those
undeclared facilities so I think right
now if they were to enrich to higher
levels it would have to be at one of
these two facilities where we have
inspectors on the ground so so you
actually you support her Benjamin
Netanyahu's position that US should
actually lay down a red line yeah well I
had an article in The Washington Post in
May where I made the case for setting
red lines and I think that there would
be a number of advantages to that and no
real disadvantages so first as I pointed
out it is in fact our red line if we're
going to use military force that would
be the last point at which it would be a
viable option you know enriching to
ninety percent so if I think making that
clear though has at least two advantages
one you might deter Iran from enriching
up to or past that level if Iran doesn't
know what our red line is I think there
would be no reason why they wouldn't
just keep inching forward and forward
whereas if we make it very clear if you
enrich above twenty percent or thirty
percent or wherever we decide to set
that red line we might be able to deter
on because they would want possibly want
to avoid a conflict second I think if it
gets to the point of using military
force the United States would want as
much domestic support as possible and
would also like as much international
political support as possible and so if
by setting a red line I think you put
the last clear chance to avoid
catastrophe on our own shoulders if it's
clear to everyone beforehand that we
don't want to use force and that well in
these force of Iran crosses this red
line and then everyone sees that Iran
makes that fateful decision to cross the
back on I think the United States would
have more support now some people point
out potential downsides to setting red
lines they say first that if you set a
red line that encourages Iran just to
push right up to that red line and then
second that it limits the president's
freedom of action and boxes them into a
corner but I think that those costs are
not that great actually because if you
just set the red line at twenty percent
or at thirty percent or some place
that's far short of what Iran would need
to do develop to develop nuclear weapons
it doesn't really matter if they push
right up to that line so I think that
first cost is not that significant and
then second in terms of limiting the
president's freedom of maneuver I think
that's only true if the president's
bluffing when he says he's using to use
willing to use force to stop Iran from
acquiring nuclear weapons so you know if
he wants to simply stand by while it run
develops nuclear weapons then that's
right setting red lines boxes him in a
little bit but if he's serious and if he
wants Iran to know that he's serious
about the military option i think that
there's no reason not to not to set the
red line so the deadline ultimately be
implemented by i ee i ee i will tell the
US president that we now have found that
they have cross the red line is that
what you're asking that's essentially
right i mean it would be up to the
United States to to declare what a red
lines are but we would be dependent on
the International Atomic Energy Agency
inspectors to tell us where we're ron's
nuclear program stands so so in other
words the signal to start the american
war will be handed over to people in
Geneva in Vienna I guess that's true
okay well thank you very much rector
chronic for speaking with us